the Jackson family points out to us that
your story's changed after Michael's
death is what they're saying they also
believed that if he were still alive you
all would not be sitting here talking to
us right now what do you say to them I
mean it's hard to speculate as to what
would be the situation if Michael was
still alive if I guess if I could
speculate if Michael was still alive and
all of the other rest of the details of
my life were the same meaning I became a
father right and I went through the same
process that I did of this realization
and going through the healing process my
belief is that we'd still be doing this
of course some details may be different
James I don't yeah I don't know what
I've taken this to my grave I certainly
planned on doing that it's a documentary
you said you planned on taking it to
your grave right so I had no
expectations of ever telling anyone
so you know if he if he was still alive
yeah yeah I don't know maybe I would
have taken it to my grave